[keyboard strokes]
Anything yet?
So far, nada. You?
Grace Ho's social media
presence is so puritan.
Every photo is of her
holding a miniature rug.
[laughs]
Ugh, she's so squeaky clean.
Is that good? Bad?
It's ideal.
It's like opening
a fresh can of Play-Doh.
[snickers]
Oh, got something.
[Chadwick on video]
Come on in, Jayne. Sit down.
That's Y.
[Chadwick on video] I'm sorry,
the other chair.
[Jayne on video] Okay.
[Chadwick on video] Yeah.
That's better.
Chadwick, you sick pup!
[Chadwick] Your grades dipped
last quarter.
- Something going on at home?
-[Jayne] Yes, sir. I...
I can't watch this, okay?
But there are
hundreds of files here.
Chadwick must have
up-skirted half the school.
You know, we have to get
these files off of his laptop
before your mom finds them.
What difference does it make
if she sees them?
This guy is despicable.
Yeah, well, karma
already got this scumbag.
His wife and his kids
don't need the embarrassment.
[groans]
We, however,
need these files.
You mean, we need to
delete them, right?
These are all kinds of wrong.
I know they are, but do you
realize what we have here?
[Jayne] He left for
Afghanistan like a year ago...
- Uh-huh.
- And we haven't heard...
We have confidential
information
on half of the school.
Transfer the files
to The Crotch drive.
Okay.
[♪]
♪ In a manner of speaking ♪
♪ I don't think
we'll be speaking ♪
♪ At all ♪
Something in here
is different.
Moved your father's boxes out
into the garage
this morning.
He can pick them up
whenever I'm not around.
How was Chadwick's vigil?
Faux.
Hmm. Happens sometimes.
You okay?
Yeah, there's just,
um, a lot going on.
How about some gin?
Might help.
Nah, you got
a winnable game going.
Sit down. I'll deal.
[chuckles]
So, have you seen
Stacey's new nose?
Looks fantastic!
Where do you run into her?
Facebook.
We play Scrabulous sometimes.
Hmm.
She's very good.
You know what? Um...
I'm tired. I think
I'm just gonna head up.
Night, Mom.
[phone pings]
[♪]
What's with the overnight bag?
And where's Hurley?
She's having a moment.
And I'm not into Ilo anymore.
We need to change direction.
Is this because of
your thing with Stacey?
- 'Cause that's not--
- No.
It's because
I don't trust Ilo.
I can't take him at his word.
Look, I'll back
whoever you want,
but voting for Hope now
would be kind of a wasted vote.
We're not backing her,
either.
Who are we backing?
What do you guys know
about Grace Ho?
- Who?
- Grace Ho.
That her name is an oxymoron?
That she looks
like a lollipop?
Oh my God!
She has a Tumblr page
about latch-hooking.
Who is this chick?
She's our
third-party candidate.
You've got to be kidding me!
The student council
makes some decisions
that we may want a say in.
We need to have the president
in our pocket.
The election is tomorrow.
What do you need us to do?
First thing, find the Ho.
[school bell rings]
[♪]
Have you seen this girl?
Her name is Grace Ho.
-I haven't. Sorry.
-Thank you.
Do you guys know
who this girl is?
No. Okay, umm...
Have either of you ladies
seen this girl, Grace Ho?
Grace Ho!
No. Okay.
[sighs]
Do you know-- Okay!
Hey, guys. Guys!
Do you know who Grace Ho is?
- No.
- Nobody?
Of course not.
Do you know this Ho?
Does a--does anyone
know this Ho?
Anyone. Please!
Hi. Do you know her?
Please say yes.
No.
[♪]
- Grace Ho?
- [bell dings]
You know my name?
- [texting]
- How would you feel
about being
president of the school?
- Is that an option?
- It is now.
You have fabulous skin.
Thank you?
Do you know who I am?
Hmm, it's actually
not that flat.
We can work with this.
- Hmm.
- Good cookies.
Thank you.
I used extra butter.
- Focus here, Grace Ho.
- Sorry.
Where do you
want to go to college?
Any of the Ivies.
And how do you think
student body president
would look on your app?
It...would be ideal.
[laughs]
Excellent.
Well, then I have one more
question for you, candidate Ho.
It concerns Mr. Chadwick's
former office.
[♪]
- [meow]
- Oh, really?
Uh, I don't get it.
Why don't you just run?
You'd win.
[laughter]
She has way too much
on her plate.
Jacket.
Oh. Look, it's reversible.
- Way worse. Thank you.
- Hands up.
Oh.
- Ohh!
- Uh, what is this thing?
- It's a sports bra.
- I know. Why are you
wearing it?
I'm on the field hockey team.
Yes, after school.
During the day,
these are assets.
- Well, I'm not really...
- Just turn around.
- Okay.
- Look, I know
the whole tits thing
undermines everything
girl power and feminist,
but biologically,
boys are simple animals,
and this bra alone
will secure you 100-plus
simple animal votes.
Remember, the key is
getting power first.
Then when you're on top,
you can make change happen.
Everything's better on top.
You're doing great.
Oh, oh?
What about my speech?
I'll take care of that later.
What I need from you now
is to hang out with us.
Uh, I can do that.
Okay then.
Here's the plan.
[meow]
[♪]
No!
Unh-unh.
[All] Ah!
[♪]
You will walk with us,
not behind us.
And concentrate
on your posture, your back
always slightly arched.
It's going to feel like
you're jutting out your chest,
because you are.
- Simple animal votes.
- Exactly.
You are never to walk
these halls alone.
Can you do that?
I guess.
You don't guess
anymore, Grace Ho.
You know.
You always know.
After each of your classes,
one of us
will be waiting for you.
- What do you have next?
- Uh, Latin.
And where does Latin
take place, other than nowhere?
C Hall, 202.
I'm in 211.
I got her.
Blast the Ho.
All Ho, all day.
- Keep breathing.
You're doing great.
- Breathe.
You are to always laugh
at our jokes,
even if you don't get them.
Never let the people know
that you're not in on the joke.
It is they who are
not in on the joke.
[laughter]
Oh, did you guys see?
I actually made
The Crotch today!
All right.
Don't get a she-boner
over it.
Act like you've
been there before.
- I assume my deal
with Farrah is off?
- [snickers]
Never even heard
of Grace Ho.
- Where'd they find her?
- [ ding ]
I think they made her
in a lab.
This is bad for me.
I'm gonna try
and make a deal
with the band.
- I may need the votes.
- What are you gonna offer them?
Same thing Hope offered them,
Chadwick's office.
- Okay.
- [bell rings]
[♪]
[humming]
[sighs]
What are you doing?
Oh, I thought I'd do
a cookie giveaway during lunch,
like Ilo did with the water.
Are your cookies
made with weed?
Uh, what?
Ilo's water was half vodka.
It was a stunt.
Oh. That's a good idea.
Well, people still
like cookies, right?
Sure. Keep making them
if you want.
Oh, you know, I had
some time in study hall,
so I worked out a few
talking points for my speech.
Here.
[♪]
You made me do it, Hope.
I offered you a deal.
Did you have something
to do with that--
I don't suppose
there's any chance
that you know how to play
bridge, is there?
I play with my nana.
Also mahjongg.
[sighs] You're perfect!
Come on.
Your jacket.
Of course you're going back
for a cookie.
You still have your apron on.
[bell rings]
Shouldn't we be in class?
We're fine.
Huh. Another trick
for the Ho.
No, that did not sound right.
[giggles] You're like
a bridge savant.
I love strategy games.
You guys ever play Dominion?
It's this game where
you have to amass assets
until you build
the most powerful kingdom
before your opponents do.
Never heard of it.
In what order
do you give your speech?
Um, my choice.
I won the coin toss.
Fantastic.
You're the closer.
It's the power position.
[Grace]
Bridge is cool, too.
I always see you guys
over here playing every day.
I just never thought
I'd actually ever be here
playing with you. [laughs]
Y-You're taking out
my bio and credentials?
Don't you think
everybody should know
all the stuff
I've been involved in here?
Like what?
Your baking proficiency?
No. It's better that
you're a mystery to them.
Think of yourself
as the new kid in school.
I've been here for ten years.
But today's the first day
you're relevant.
No offense.
Dominating win for Hurley-Ho.
All right,
30, 70, 100, 130... 340.
Can I make
a gameplay suggestion?
Don't come out too strong.
Say you have a queen
and an ace of spades--
I am shortening
this snooze-fest
in the middle by half.
Actually, by a whole.
It's gone.
That pretty much leaves me
saying hello and then goodbye.
I lost the goodbye, too.
We need a stronger closer.
Going last means
you control the walk-away.
When they exit the auditorium,
Grace Ho needs to be
the only name
that they remember.
How do I accomplish that?
We need a hook.
I'll go find him.
I don't want to sound skeptical,
but don't you think I should
say something of substance?
I mean, you're the one who said
that Ilo's already cut deals
with half the factions
in school.
Okay. Look,
these circles represent
the voting blocs in the school.
Now the vote is tomorrow,
and Ilo already has
most of the blocs,
but that doesn't mean
that we're done yet.
What do we do?
We fracture the groups
and regroup them
into one larger voting bloc.
Women.
Fifty-four percent
of the school is female--
girls who are dying
to be seen and heard.
By tomorrow,
you'll have a speech
that speaks directly to them.
I'll get it to you
in the morning
so you can practice with it.
And until then,
the Janes and Hurley
will stay by your side
all through dinner.
Be seen.
As much as possible.
Got it?
This is an awful speech.
- My mom edited it.
- No. No, no, no.
- [Man on video] I would advise
looking at some better schools.
- Wow!
Are you aware
that Debjit Cheema
got a 1530 on the SATs?
What? But he's a moron!
Yeah.
How's the speech coming?
Actually,
I think I'm done.
Nice!
Um...
do you wanna maybe
hang out a little?
- Why?
- I don't know,
but you could tell me
how you figured out
that I was the one
behind The Crotch curtain.
Or you could tell me
who you inherited
The Crotch curtain from.
How about just hanging out
because it's better than going
back to your house right now?
Hmm?
Okay.
Um, do you wanna listen
to some music?
Sure.
[rock music playing on phone]
Who is this?
Just hold still for once,
okay? Listen.
This band could literally
change your life.
[music playing]
Wait. Wait.
So, is it over, officially?
Is what over officially?
Your dad.
Is he gone gone?
I'm not posting
a story about it.
I wouldn't do that to you.
Yeah, because I could out you.
No, because I wouldn't
do that to you.
And I actually care
what you think of me.
What is that supposed to mean?
Well, I've seen your shave,
and yet, at school,
you treat me like I'm invisible,
just like everybody else.
Yeah, which is me
protecting us.
Is it?
My dad's stuff is in boxes.
In the garage.
Which it turns out is easier
than seeing it piled up
in the dining room.
What do you mean?
I mean, it's easier
not to see all of that
when I'm sitting at the table
where we used to have
family dinners.
Sorry. I should've
gotten that.
I'm just so angry at him.
I mean, not because of
what he did to my family.
I mean, that's obvious.
I'm just angry because
while he's out there
doing whatever with whoever,
I'm stuck being my mom's
only source of entertainment.
I mean, other than
Stacey Moorehead
and her fabulous
Scrabulous skills,
which I cannot even deal with.
Well, I get that.
I have, uh, been my mom's only
source of entertainment since,
- you know...
- Yeah.
It's exhausting.
[music continues]
This is actually
kind of a good song.
Yeah? And in English, too.
What is with you
and like, the French music?
Oh, no, no.
You've gotten enough
out of me today.
Okay.
[♪]
- Less smoky, more trustworthy.
- Gotcha.
- How ya feelin'?
- Scared.
- You're gonna do great.
- Thanks.
You got this, Hook?
As long as she
keeps her end up,
I'll make it happen.
- Grace?
- Yeah, of course. I'm in.
Do you think anyone will really
connect with this part?
They all will.
[bell rings]
All right, guys.
Election assembly after lunch.
Until then the plan
is the same as yesterday.
Y, you've got her homeroom
and first period.
I got her second
and third.
Hey, you've got this.
Okay?
Are you sure?
Just remember to connect
with the emotion in this speech.
Got me?
I will catch up
with you later.
Hey, Lynn. Are you ready
for the uh, big vote today?
It doesn't really matter
who's president.
My year doesn't change.
I mean, you don't know that.
The student president controls
a five-figure event budget,
- they have a seat--
- It's just a popularity contest
where the winner
chooses the theme for prom.
[sighs] I mean,
if you feel that way,
then this is your chance
to prevent
another Under the Sea debacle.
It was so loud last year, too.
Right?
I couldn't tell
from the pictures.
Oh.
Well, I can understand
how you saw the theme
and chose to sit that one out.
You made the right choice.
You don't have to do that.
We both know nobody asked me.
Like I said, my year
doesn't change either way.
No, I-- I didn't--
Vote for Grace.
[whistle blows]
[♪]
In closing, you can vote
for any candidate you want,
but really think about
what they stand for.
And what you know about 'em.
I mean, come on.
Who's Grace Ho, really?
- [laughter]
- Look...
in the end, you have to
vote for a known quantity,
and that's me.
Vote for Ilo!
[cheers and applause]
[cheers continue]
[booing]
I've had a speech
prepared for this moment
- since I was 9 years old...
- [Boy] Nobody wants you here!
but now, not so much.
I...wasn't even
going to show up here today,
but I realized that I'll never
have the opportunity
to apologize to all of you
at once.
Here goes.
I am truly sorry if I hurt
anyone with what I said.
I want you to know
that I understand
that what I said is wrong...
and that I have a problem.
So, I have taken it upon myself
to enroll in
sensitivity classes.
[derisive laughter]
And I intend to prove to you
all that I was, am,
and will be a worthy candidate.
- [booing]
- Thank you.
[shouting] Grace Ho!
[Grace clears throat]
[microphone feeds back]
I'm gonna make this
short and sweet
because I know how uncomfortable
those chairs are.
What is she doing?
Back on point, Ho.
[clears throat]
Candidate Ilo stood here
a few moments ago
and said that you all
don't know me,
but I think he's wrong.
You do know me.
Look, if you want to vote
for some guy
because he has great eyes
and abs,
then go ahead.
But don't be surprised if
after you fall for him,
he asks you to
park in his garage
so that his friends don't see
your car parked at his house.
[people murmuring]
At least with me,
you know what you're getting...
because...
I'm you...
and you... and you.
I'm a girl
who comes in every day
hoping that today's the day
that someone notices me.
I'm a girl
who wants a cool event
to go to on the weekends
because I want
at least one cool story
to tell people
when I go to college.
I'm a girl who wants
a high school experience
like you see on TV
where I flirt with a cute guy
and make out on the swing set.
I'm you.
Even if you didn't recognize me
until yesterday.
So, if every one of you drop
a check in the Grace Ho box,
then we win, not me.
We.
[shouting]
Grace! Ho!
[chanting continues]
[electrical static]
[music plays]
[both] Whoo!
A landslide.
You did it.
Yeah we did.
[loudly] Later, Colin!
Bye, Farrah.
[bell rings]
[♪]
[Grace]
Farrah!
Farrah, wait up!
Congratulations, El Jefe.
I just wanna say thanks.
For everything.
- This is so cool!
- Not a problem.
There's still one thing
I don't get.
Why me?
You didn't even know me.
I like a Cinderella story.
So, can I ask you, what now?
What do you mean?
Tomorrow.
What do I do?
Uh, you keep your end
of the bargain
and build a private
handicap bathroom.
I will.
I just meant about us.
Oh. Let's plan
a weekly meet.
Sound good?
Bye.
[♪]
[Farrah] Grace Ho
has a lot going for her.
Pretty, smart, and now
she has a killer look.
It's really too bad
she had to try
and give the Janes
bridge pointers.
Why give away an advantage
when you don't need to?
When all is said and done,
and she's at Harvard
or whatever Ivy,
she'll look back on this
and realize
I gave her
exactly what she wanted.
[Stacey]
I've been there.
What?
That's how it starts with her.
[sighs] Good luck.
[♪]
[Farrah] On the plus side,
the same weakness
that made Grace Ho want to help
the Janes in bridge
makes me quite certain
that she'll keep up her end
of our little bathroom deal.
- Hey, Farrah.
- Hey, Mrs. Davies!
I just talked to Will
at college.
He asked if I'd seen you
and wanted to know
how you're doing.
Tell him that you have,
and that I'm doing great.
Hey, Woogie. How's
freshman year treating you?
Fine so far.
Mostly because you haven't been
calling me Woogie at school.
- [laughs] So, who do you have
for English class?
- Mrs. Koenig.
[Farrah] Oh, and I've already
emailed Grace Ho
some bathroom tile choices.
[♪]
Who shit in
your sandwich?
Your little Grace Ho
puppet did.
But I don't think
pulling her strings
is gonna be
as easy as you think.
I'm not a very good liar.
Don't forget how you got here.
[siren wails]
Today, I identify
as a woman.
Your move, girlfriend.
[Hope] Grace was right.
I can't think of a single thing
Farrah's done for me
that didn't benefit
her more.
Since when does
her keeping stuff from us
seem weird to you?
She is full-on flirting
with Will right now.
Nice style, Grace.
Where'd you get it?
What illegalist thing
do you need me to do now?
[Farrah] We need to leak this.
[Cowher] My mom
could lose her job.
I want to break
into her email.
She's your hacker?
The Crotch holds power.
Barely tapped into it.
- Don't!
- This is a huge story!
The Crotch
has no moral compass.
That post violates me
in so many ways!
[both exclaim]
You're screwing
with a kid's life here.
I don't know what to do!
You know what
your problem is?
You actually believe
that you should decide
what's best for other people.
♪ Everyone tells you
how to live ♪
♪ But they don't know how
to do it ♪
I have to burn
the whole thing down.
I'm not gonna let you
burn it down without me.
Ready for the fallout?
Bring it on.